raided our daily lives fostering a
society that's inclined to distraction
and inattention it's an hour in ten
minutes okay we're ready to start
good evening I'm Barbara Meade I'm one
of the owners here of politics and prose
I want to welcome Todd Gitlin to
politics and prose for a return visit
this is probably his third we were just
trying to recollect before but it's been
a long relationship that we've had with
them with him neither of us will
disagree about that delegate Lynn is a
professor of journalism sociology and
culture at New York University Press
I'm sorry New York you know York
University College University New York
University okay
he obviously covers a lot of territory
there I found this book very very
interesting I was thinking about it
again after we had a very absorbing
evening the other night with Ahmed
Rashid the author of jihad it was a
tremendously hostile evening toward
media people in the audience and Ahmad
Rashid himself seemed to hold the media
responsible for a lot of the problems
that were going on in Central Asia that
the media hadn't covered it in depth
that they were too shallow and they're
reporting that they were just interested
in sound bites and of course that's
exactly what the Todd Gitlin is doing is
talking about in his book one of the
things I think that we need to find out
this evening which I'm curious about is
which comes first the chicken or the egg
in this situation was that an audience
who said that we refused to listen to
something that is longer than 15 seconds
in its presentation or was it a media
who said that we're not going to give
you anything longer than 15 seconds in
this presentation and so it shut down
the attention span of the audience I'm
sure the target learner is going to talk
to all these things and we're going to
have a very nice evening thanks Thank
You Barbara it is actually wonderful to
be back here where I think the National
Center of seriousness I I seem in my old
age to become a chicken-egg specialist
let me try to describe how I came to
this book which is rather different from
what I've done before some of you may
know that I have been one I have been a
rail or at media for eons I began my
interest in the media as an activist of
the 1960s
being struck by the discrepancy between
the images and renditions of experience
that were retailed through media and
what I knew myself through my own
experience as an activist in the
anti-war and New Left movement and that
produced a book called the war whole
world is watching in which I tried to
account for this discrepancy and to
explore the question of its consequences
I then proceeded to try to ask similar
questions about the entertainment
business I was interested in how the
industry that's in the business of
producing entertainment goes about
processing reality social conflict in
particular in
two television programs and so I
produced the book about how the
television industry works it's a it's an
industrial analysis and but but these
were books of the early eighties and at
the time I was teaching at Berkeley and
I was teaching courses in media and
sociology and I was struck by but uneasy
at the same time about the fact that my
students while nominally persuaded of
some of the arguments that I was making
we're living in a different world than
the world I had grown up in I was ten
years old when we got television and
this had an interesting consequence
which namely that I didn't know quite
how to tell them how odd was the world
in which they were living a world in
which so much of their attention is
given up to media images and sounds or
to put it another way having written
books about where media images came from
I was then and in the course of
subsequent years in which I've written
lots of articles about different aspects
of media persuaded that I was missing
the big story that I had some answers to
questions like where do media get their
ideas and what good are they or not good
but the enormity of the connection that
we have to media as a civilization or
the very fact that media experience is a
central feature of our civilization I
couldn't quite yet get my mind around it
and even if just a few years ago when I
had decided to collect much of what I
had written about media over the last
twenty years into a book
I took some inner striving before I
could get my mind around what I came to
think of as the big idea about media my
big idea about media which I will
present to you as
present as I do at the beginning of the
book in the form of a parable and it is
this a customs guard goes to work and
one day there rolls up to his station a
truck and the official the guard asks
the driver some questions and the driver
answers them and the guard waves him
through the next week the same truck
driver is back and this time the guard
is a little suspicious there's something
about the guy that doesn't quite ring
right so he asked him some more
questions the guy asked him answers them
to his satisfaction and he's waved
through the next week he's the truck
driver is back in this time the guard
orders him out of the cab of the truck
and does a search and waves the guy
through in the next week he's back in
this time a more thorough search and
this time some equipment is rolled up
x-ray equipment and so on in various
parts of the truck or searched and
nothing is found he waves and through
and this goes on for many years more
more elaborate equipment comes into play
sonar unknown technologies this goes on
for years and never does the guard find
anything on this truck driver finally
the guard is about to retire some of you
may recognize a comparable parable
that's told by Kafka at the end of the
trial the guard is reaching retirement
age and up rawls the truck driver and
the guard says to him look on you know
we've known each other in this way all
these years and I'm about to retire and
I must have some satisfaction I know you
have been smuggling contraband all these
years and now I must know what you've
been smuggling
I will never inform anyone I can do you
no harm
what have you been smuggling and the
truck driver says trucks
this turns out to be a parable told in
the there's a Sufi version of it in
which it's donkeys and in in Germany I
heard a bicycle version in Spain also
the trucks are the habit of living with
the media the media have been smuggling
the habit of living with the media and
the practice or the experience of living
with media living immersed in a
experience of living with media living
immersed in a tremendous torrent of
media some of it ostensibly chosen
voluntarily and some of it imposed this
enormity has become a central activity
or inactivity of our existence and we
don't quite acknowledge it that is if I
told you if I regaled you with
statistics about the six and
three-quarter hours that American
children spend with media each day or
the seven plus hours a day that each
household is attending to television
alone and many other such statistics in
which the United States tends to lead if
that's the right word the developed
world although in some by some measures
other countries are ahead if I if I told
you if I told you these numbers I'm not
sure that I could still I that I could
yet succeed in persuading you that
there's something both natural and
really odd about this really really
peculiar that we have evolved a
civilization in which most of the people
we will ever be hold will be faces on
screens people we will never meet and
most of the sounds most of the people
whom we meet in the form of sound
whether it's speech or song or
what-have-you
will be likewise people we will never
meet and that never before in human
history have so many such
images been available to so many such
people so that our experience with these
people and with the stories that
circulate around them our experience
with this media this media torrent is
the major form of activity we undertake
except for sleeping and working and even
as I think many of us will admit at
least in the in the odd recesses of our
days even some of the time we spend
working is spent in contact with media
whether it's listening to the radio or
to CDs or playing various games on the
internet that we may or may not dignify
on with the word information so what I
set out to do was somewhere there was
not for me in a ha moment but somewhere
when I when I when I tried to get when I
set out to get my mind around the fact
that this has become what we do to a
considerable degree I then tried to
think out again where this came from how
this happened now there there are
essentially two approaches to this
question and both of them are necessary
one of them with which I think we're
fairly familiar is that there have come
to be attention-getting institutions
that's set out to collect our eyeballs
or our eardrums which are then useful to
them for various purposes and that this
is not especially new in history states
have generated images of the of royalty
whether stamped on the sides of coins or
in posed in the form of of icons and and
religions have generated icons and and
paintings of saints frescoes and whatnot
it's not surprising that they would do
that for their purposes namely of
winning loyalty nor in in our time and
for the last century or so is it is it
surprising that there should be
profit-making organizations that have a
compelling interest in collecting our
attention because our attention is after
all a valuable commodity to them it's
our attention that is what they sell to
advertisers so I find that important
obviously I think and anyone who's not a
fool would considers it important in by
way of explaining how we have become a
media saturated civilization
it certainly is important to to grasp
that there are strong institutions that
have urged us to behave in this way
but to me that won't suffice and on all
these years when I've been writing about
media institutions and interlocutors on
the radio or students have said yeah but
after all aren't we choosing to do this
and I have made arguments which I think
are half true about the fact that well
when the atmosphere is saturated with
these images and sounds and so on it's
not exactly a pure unguided choice but
but I have at the same time known that
this was not an adequate explanation for
the delights that most people in our
civilization find in the stream of
images and sounds with which they we
wrap ourselves and so I then in in
thinking out this book try to imagine
myself into the situation of people who
are spending large portions of their
lives in connection with media which
they derive some satisfaction from and
here I'm not talking about the the
impositions of media which I do write
about in this book and which I think are
important namely everything from
elevator music to the on screen
inescapable CN n screen in an airport
waiting room or on the
back of the seed of the plane of the
seat in front of you on the plane or the
the cellphone rings or the internet of
pop-up ads or the billboards or a whole
lot of other impositions
but if we think about the the world of
media that most of us feel in a sense
flattered by or gifted by the ones that
we seek more and more of whether in the
form of multiple channel cable or faster
modem internet or scan buttons on the
radio or overstuffed newsstand magazine
racks I think the truth is that while we
talk about ourselves as information
gatherers as we like to think that
mainly what we're doing is collecting
information I think that that's actually
a disguise in the main in the main I
think the dirty little secret is that
what we're in the media torrent for is
feelings that is either the sorts of you
know happiness or fright or indignation
or a sense of control or erotic
sensations or all kinds of sue anger all
kinds of things that we bring into our
skin when we behold or or partake of
media but also the even even even the
news that we turn to even the snippets
of information the sound bytes and so on
that constitute the the normal
information diet that it's it's it's
it's disingenuous to say that we're in
this for information most of the
information that we get most of the
snippets of fact that come to us in this
fashion are in and out are of our minds
they just pass through like cosmic rays
and but I think that that the the truth
is that mainly what we are doing is
collecting a
of sensation even if it's just the
pleasure of feeling knowledgeable a kind
of sensation who's very destiny is to be
evanescent is to be transient the
feelings that we get through our media
experience are our disposable feelings
now if that's that's my that's my
hypothesis now if there's if there's any
truth to that then then that that raises
the next question which is why should we
be in the business of feeling so much
what what's that that's that's also sort
of odd for most of human history people
haven't had the luxury they were busy
hunting or gathering or farming or were
or working in the mines so there's an
oddity here that in a perversity that
that the great dream of development
which became the dominant dream of the
West and which catered to the desires of
people to transform themselves to
transform themselves so that having been
born a serf they would not have to
remain a serf or being born a peasant
they would not have to remain a peasant
or a slave or what-have-you
the great idea of self transformation
which is still the dominant value that
is adhere to I think not not only here
but among those who have love-hate
relations with the United States of
America this great ideal has somehow
been reduced in our actual lives not not
the values that we declare to find us
but in what we actually do to a much
safer more convenient most undemanding
form of activity in which we transform
ourselves in a minor way without
actually having to do anything we can do
it with a remote control device or a
Sony Walkman we can do it at home and we
can carry it around on
ears what we can do is is enjoy but
enjoy in a way that doesn't really offer
a deep satisfaction if it did actually
we might not need the next program song
story etc so it's a disposable emotion
it's an emotion that tickles
and and invites the next media blip the
next moment now this is this is
something that did not just happen
nor was it simply the product of
television networks which of course
avail themselves of our attention and
our emotional hunger as as suits them
nor is it simply the product of I
believe of Hollywood or even of the
electric phonograph or the technologies
that preceded if you read Tocqueville's
great description of American culture in
the 1830s in the second volume of
democracy in America you read about a
fidgety shallow culture that is invited
by and soothing to Americans who don't
want to take too many chances don't want
to live too dangerously who want to be
satisfied Tocqueville writes this and
it's it's a description that I recognize
even though it predates Hollywood for 60
years well I try to go back even further
in history to to look at how how America
was itself the product of the European
ideal and it was an ideal of self
creation with minimal risk I don't have
time to to take you down those ways well
this book is about the torrent and
that's a kind of Zen moment to alert to
alert me to move on I try in this book
also to talk about it what I think is it
is it increasingly evident and
disturbing element of the media torrent
which is speed the speed at many levels
the the the speed with which new
cultural items appear the speed with
which with which the old is real old its
you know what it is same old same old
it's a history that's what we say in
America if we think it's time to
escorter history I try to talk also
about the speed with which images move
look at any movie of the 1960s even and
it'll look really slow look at
commercials of that period and they will
be the proverbial drying paint before
your eyes sound bites a very clear sign
of this this is something that's been
well studied by Kaku idato and Daniel
halan in 1968 within the lifetimes of
most of us in this room the average
soundbite by a candidate during the
presidential election lasted for 45
seconds in the most recent election it
was down around 8 seconds the somebody
told me the other day about a programmer
at a major AM radio station in New York
City the way in which the playlist for
Songs was made up was that a test
audience was gathered in an auditorium
and a sequence of songs were played or
rather while the audience held but held
buttons with which to rate whether they
liked it or not
seven seconds each of a song was played
before the next one was moved on to and
so if the song doesn't you know doesn't
get you within seven songs seven seconds
it's history and by the way the scan
button that's on every new radio that's
been produced car radio in America since
I believe the late 70s also is on a
seven second
system.if if you're not grabbed then
then it's wrong I I did look for things
that I could count as a one time
mathematician I'm interested in evidence
it's very hard to trust people's
recollections of how fast life was
people have been complaining about the
onrush of speed at least two centuries
which to my mind doesn't mean that they
were wrong I think they were right all
along but I looking for something I
could count I decided to look at to see
if we could express a hunch at least
about the impact of reading and the
impact on reading and reading styles and
reading preferences of the fact that the
media acceleration has been upon us and
the acceleration of the rest of life as
well so I looked at certain features of
bestselling novels going back to the
1930s I looked at I took sentences at
random from each of these books and I
looked at the length of the sentences
that were randomly chosen and also the
complexity of these sentences as
measured by the number of punctuation
marks in the sentence and pretty well
it's not it's not exact but pretty well
from 1936 onward the sentences would be
getting shorter and they'd be getting
simpler if you go back further I Col egh
join me in this effort after I published
a short version of this Geoffrey nunberg
a very good linguist studied sentences
in the New York Times and science
magazine interestingly enough going back
into the 19th century and he found
essentially the same process not again
unvarnished but varnished the tendency
is there the big acceleration in the
shortening of these sentences and the
simplification takes place in the 1950s
through 70s which is the period when
television is becoming a fixture of
American culture I then looked at the
same thing with respect to popular
like National Geographic and the New
York Times magazine and found
essentially the same thing so the
speed-up which leads to our sort of
manic longing to multitask and see more
things at once and have crawls on the
screen and have in faster modems and all
of this this this speed up is is
manifest I think in multiple ways and
and leads to what I think at the risk of
a bit of rhetorical excess I would call
it a national attention deficit disorder
which which does speak to the question
actually of whether we are well served
by our informational media since so
little time is spent with anything and
the rush to move to the next subject the
next story the next snippet and the and
the the imperative or they don't know if
that's the right word the obsession with
stacking more sound bytes more more
visual cues more logos more more Dow
numbers and weather numbers and so on on
the screen
the obsession with that that people
practice on for themselves of watching
television and the Internet at the same
time or you know trying to follow the
crawl on the screen while you're paying
as much attention as you can to the
story and so on all this I think it
leads to a kind of fit fulness and and a
kind of twitch in our culture which as a
teacher I recognize also as an
impediment to clear thinking I think you
know increasingly you find students who
are smart in the sense that they know
they know they're interested in fact and
they are able to reason when pressed to
do so but the the snippet mentality the
soundbite mentality it goes along with a
sense that they have that there's
nothing in the world but facts nothing
that is a disconnected facts facts
without order or
system that all opinions are simply that
they're all equivalent opinions and
therefore one is edified if you hear a
lot of barking heads shouting each other
on Sunday morning or every afternoon
that this that that that that logic and
evidence have no place that the mission
of a pundit is to pound the table and to
humiliate an opponent rather than to
take on the opponent's argument at its
strong point rather than scoring
debating points and so and I think all
these all these things are connected to
a fevered on rush of immersion in a
media torrent now where are we in all
this my view is that all of us are at
some level aware that we're too busy
there's too much coming at us this or
that isn't very good that we see you on
the screen or at the movies and so on
we all have hopes that for improvement
which I share my argument is that about
how we cope is that everybody has to
cope that there's so much coming at you
so many slogans brands logos everything
I've described it you know they're now
staring at you at the urinal they are
you know they're that sports scores are
radiating from the stalks tops of the
taxis in New York this is this season
that everybody works out navigational
strategies to manage this flow and that
they this actually explains some of the
oddities of our culture for example it
explains something of the celebrity
fascination because one thing you can do
when you're regaled by unending images
and sounds is to develop a principle of
discrimination that is it's it's it's to
root so so the fan is somebody who says
Halle Berry she's my gal and Britney
Spears I rule out so a fan is somebody
has a principle of selection I will read
all the fat how
various stories I will no not have to
pay attention to thee I'm
oversimplifying but but I think fan all
of us are fans to some way or other and
we enjoy the experience of proximity to
someone who seems to have risen above
the the mirror every day fans are people
who are trying to adapt in a certain way
critics ourselves and I count myself as
one of them a critic is somebody who
flatters him or herself that by getting
the better of intellectually getting the
better of or aesthetically getting the
better of this or that we have somehow
proved that we're not like ordinary
people but we are and everybody is to
some degree a critic is that they
disagree about what they're critical
about we are exhibitionists
exhibitionists are people who want to be
more than receptors they want to be
emitters of signal so whether it's
holding up a sign at a basketball game
saying hi NBC I'm here or setting up a
24 hour web camera and exhibiting your
entire life or doing amateur or
pornography or for that matter you know
calling call-in shows and so on these
are also ways in which we feel that we
have a bit of mastery of what is
otherwise a kind of unending rule we are
some of us our culture jammers we think
that by hacking a website or by defacing
a poster we can lay hold of something
that is emitting propaganda at us and
and fight back some of us many of us are
IRA nests we think oh yes well of course
a lot of what we see or hear is drunk
but you're an idiot for taking it
seriously and anyway isn't it sort of
amusing to watch old sitcoms or to make
you know jokes about you know
Ted Koppel's hair or something like that
that's the note the notion that you know
Graydon Carter was widely quoted after
September 11th as saying in a line I'm
sure he wishes he could take back that
the age of irony was over this was in
one of these sort of instant another
media phenomenon by the way sort of how
has everything changed entirely for the
rest of human history surveys published
on September 13th or so in which he
announced that the age of irony was over
well I haven't noticed that maybe maybe
he needs a new profession but in any
case there are other such devices
finally and I and I will conclude
rapidly I'm interested in the final
portion of this book in how it happens
that America this American popular
culture which is in its own way
both enticing and weightless arousing
and stupefying why how it gets so
handily around the world
why coca-cola Schwarzenegger Bruce
Willis are celebrities everyone knows
why the why American icons why the
Academy Awards ceremony I'm sure was
watched you know by a billion and a half
or two billion people last night what's
what's this about and again as with the
rest of my analysis I think that there
obviously is an industrial side to this
America is is very good at industrial
production and commerce and we produce
we have economies of scale once you've
produced a movie you can strike off a
new print very cheap and then all the
rest of the profit is gravy so it's not
surprising that roughly half of
Hollywood studio profits now come from
outside the United States and there are
other aspects of American culture that I
think make us well-heeled as it were to
to address the rest of the world because
American culture is an import culture
you know we we American music is based
on African music American comedy is
based on Italian Jewish and also African
black American we are a culture that
never having had to be a high culture
never having to fight away from high
culture have always been in the business
of Commerce we've always American
popular culture has always been popular
which was not true elsewhere we didn't
have to fight against cultural elites
here it's rather amusing that people
like you know Steven Spielberg are
considered cultural elites in America I
mean these enough said ok but I also
argue in this part of the book that as
with Americans that people elsewhere are
also not in general being dragooon dat
gunpoint to see to listen to American
hip-hop or rock music or to cease
Schwarzenegger movies that there's
something in American styles including
the much despised Disney styles of hyper
innocence which have an appeal to people
elsewhere and are adopted therefore
sometimes against the powers of the
countries themselves you know American
hip-hop music and slogans and so on are
picked up by North African kids living
in the slums in the suburbs of Paris
because they're usable to express
disdain for French elites and this is
also an important part of the story so
my my piece here my my clothes is not to
rail against the American abomination
but it's to see America as so often
before as that force which is both you
know which people love to hate because
America is in a sense the advanced guard
like it or not of a ma of a movement of
modernity that has generated an ideal of
freedom
and then carved it or or siphoned it
that are siphoned it to stay with the
nautical metaphor siphoned it into a set
of formulas and habits that alas leave
us not at the peak of civilization but I
think rather staring at something that
we ought to feel mighty uncomfortable
about that that it's to these incessant
signs symbols stories sounds that we
have given so much of our lives I'm
sorry to have rattled on a bit long
there but I would love to have your
questions remember for those of you who
have questions to please get a line up
at the mic over here thank you
I taught I was wondering what's your
views as a media critic of radical
sociologists what have you what they
mean or what they pretend for the future
of dissent in America you had a
wonderful line out paraphrase that I may
not remember that exactly where you said
in the era of the soundbite the
one-liner is King and there's a certain
satirical devilishness about that and I
was wondering how do you how can you
stand outside the problem the phenomenon
that you're critiquing and communicate
your message to people ironically one of
the great books in this tradition if I
could take the liberty it's amusing
ourselves death by Neil postman when
your colleagues and it is a book that is
written with its short sentences its
short paragraphs for a you know
precisely the kind of generation that
it's critiquing so I guess my question
is how do you advance the radical
critique and at the same time avoid
falling victim to the very thing that
you're challenging with difficulty
I haven't actually counted the length of
my own sentences and I actually am
rather partial to flowing sentences with
subordinate clauses but I haven't
checked to see how many of those have
because I also like I also like Rock'em
Sock'em sentences first of all the the
media although people tend to speak of
it as in it is not in it it's a
grammatical error that expresses a
certain truth namely a lot of this stuff
sounds the same but if we compare the
the array of media possibilities Media
technologies today to the array of
possibilities in you know in the 1960s
the media are far freer today than they
were then the world of ABC NBC CBS the
you know one or two serious newspapers
in America and was not a was not a world
of of media vitality and in fact this
this goes to a point I think that is
often a point of romance that is often
made about the 1960s that we learned the
truth about the Vietnam War through
American journalism well I beg to differ
I think that many of us learned the
truth about the Vietnam War through some
journalism but much journalism was
rather well enlisted if not in the
claims being made by the US government
but in the objectives being stated by
the US government that the dissent has
been rather exaggerated in retrospect
let's not forget that the Gulf of Tonkin
incident was reported rather
uncritically in 1964 leading to a kind
of carte blanche embrace of what turned
out to be a absolutely catastrophic war
for everyone and this was at a time when
media ownership was not in
is concentrated as today and so on so I
think that I'm as you can tell I'm
opposed to using the media as an alibi I
think that there are plenty of problems
that dissidents have this would take us
to my next book actually there are
plenty of problems that activists have
and it should be taken as a given that
the large profit-making organizations
like television networks or news
magazines are not especially enamored of
descent and will find ways to trivialize
it and compress it and or marginalize it
or disguise it or flatten it and you
know it seems to me that goes with the
territory
but I also want to say that the the
internet I'm not an internet utopian
some people proclaim that the old age
was over because we now had
interactivity and we were now going to
be netizens and and so on I think that's
extremely naive however there are around
the internet sites and sounds that are
that are edifying and that are trying to
conduct politics on it and and for that
matter other sorts of mind work on a
different plane I'll just if I can abuse
the privilege I'm associated as a North
American editor with a website called
open democracy which is open democracy
dotnet which was started in London it's
been going for less than a year now on a
shoestring and it's it's principles are
have discussion on big things big
matters of our time you know future of
globalization Europe war media etc make
it cross-national make it smart and urge
writers not to score cheap shot points
but to engage others at their at the
strong points of the other argument
anyway this thing has been growing its
trust national you know it after
September 11th we ran articles from
Pakistan and
from from Israel and and and and you
know all over Europe and and India and
China I mean it's a kind of wonderful
thing to see that there are you know
there are adult minded people who are
curious about the world and and I would
add just the level of information that
to be able to access Indian newspapers
which I did
Pakistani newspapers and so on about
that Afghanistan was kind of remarkable
I mean I got into arguments because if
something I published with with people
in India and I you know this is
fantastic and you know we're right at
the beginning of this I mean to think
that we know what the Internet is gonna
be in 2002 is is rather silly I mean
very few people have had it for more
than maybe seven years which which in if
we think about radio terms in that in in
terms of the history of radio we've you
know we would be around 1923 and
television and radio was barely
commercial at that point so I'm not a
I'm not a hype stir about it but but
there is space for people who are
committed to doing something else so I'm
so that's my long-winded answer to that
question yes
actually I think I was next if I may um
I wondered if you thought this problem
was worse in the United States than it
is in other countries like Canada or
England Western Europe or even countries
like Japan or Taiwan and if it is worse
here why the Japanese actually watch
more television than we do and they are
also obviously very much pioneers of
technology that makes the media torrent
rush faster the not least the Sony
Walkman and it's variants Europe in if
it's statistically speaking Europeans
tend to be behind us in electronic media
use but not very far behind you know
Americans watch about four and a half
hours of television a day the French
it's between three and a half and four
hours so the u.s. is the advanced guard
of this phenomenon but but not it's not
a tremendous difference I was I just
spent a week in Toronto the there's you
can say they're very good things to be
said about the some of the Canadian
press but most Canadian television is
not only directly piped in from this
side of the border but it's imitative of
it it's extremely imitative so I think
we're dealing with something that is
that that extends beyond the the
American boundary the world is the the
numbers are going up in I lived in
Britain for five months last year I I
tend to be rather starry-eyed about the
BBC and I'm still starry-eyed about some
of BBC Radio everywhere I mean this is a
culture in which to have serious radio
is is considered an entitlement but tell
British television strikes me as in part
of the same world we're in you know the
overloading of the news with with logos
and whiz-bang talk and
and and even soundtrack music is present
in Britain though the British news I
think remain the British interviewer is
still a delight British interviewer is
someone who does homework who does a
protracted interview who doesn't enjoy
in this sort of you know over au Pitre
sort of chat and these are you know
these are you know terrific people like
John you know interviewers like John
snow on Channel four and and some of the
BBC people it's quite wonderful but the
same tendency is going and the British
press well my goodness
I mean it's stupendous tabloid press
most of the people who were I know a
number of people who work in
documentaries and news and they are all
tearing their hair about the tabloid
ization of everything it's many people
think that the BBC will lose within the
next decade it's privileged position
which comes from the fact that they have
claims to a licence fee that everybody
must pay to have a television set
legally that's how the BBC is financed
and they fear they're going to lose it
because more channels are coming in
cable Murdoch has operations going and
so on so I see you know it's not a pure
convergence there there there are still
differences and and they're worth
cherishing but I think the direction
that I have described is the dominant
not the only but it's the dominant
direction yes very pessimistic in a way
but I think NPR's uh I used I worked on
NPR and I think that audience is growing
and I think someday commercial radio at
least might figure out that people do
like more than fifteen 30-second stories
that a four or five minute story works
but it seems to mean more all of this is
more of a a generation thing a
generation that's been raised on Sesame
Street in in the fifteen thirty second
sound bites and and
seems that some of it there is some news
research now that's showing that that
kids can learn things you can win it's
10 minutes long or 15 minutes long and
horrors that I know that might be a
there might be a change coming there
where we where we really think kids have
a longer attention span but worries me
more about the media is this the
commercialization that they the the
commerce is of the thing that's driving
these these short term spans a whole
Letterman thing that we just saw Ted
Koppel Letterman thing the marketer
marketeers of the the younger generation
who think the more serious news is
irrelevant that that's the kind of thing
that I'm aren't concerned about but I
lived abroad a number of years too and I
I think one reason it is just so
seductive or our media is that it is
just so much fun in many ways I mean
kids love to come here because it's so
much fun and I think partly it's so much
fun is because it's not tied down
entrenched in the old histories that
they have and some way I say I think
illiteracy of history it's might be a
good thing here in the states that we're
not tied down with the old Wars the Old
Earth NIC rivalries but whatever Italy
forgets to come here and just have this
kind of superficiality concerned with
the media present and not concerned with
the past all the time so I think that's
part of the seductiveness I
I think NPR is awfully important as I go
around doing doing radio you know it
still remains blissfully true that you
know the odds are if you're interviewed
by somebody on on an NPR station that
this person is read your book which is a
real treat it's really a thrill and and
I think that the commercial danger
exists in both public radio and public
television as well the sponsorship of
programs on public television in
particular I think
for itself as a as a force and and we
still collectively don't value our
public nature enough to fund our system
like grown-ups it's it's begrudging
about children I think this is awfully
important I was I was at a bookstore in
Chicago last week and there were some
teachers there who were alarmed and I
thought rightly alarmed at the fact that
kids come in to school having already
watched you know a couple of hours of
television and and the teacher who used
that figure with somebody who had taught
in an inner-city school where she had
that experience and then she went to
teach at a prior ANSI private school and
had the same experience
and while Sesame Street I think you know
it I think it deserves some blame for
this the study you know there were
people who thought they could
meticulously study the impact of it and
I've never seen any evidence that was
persuasive that that it was the
jerkiness of Sesame Street in particular
that was making kids a little wacky but
the surely the profusion of attention
deficit disorder that has turned ritalin
into you know sort of the second most
popular drug after coca-cola is almost
certainly not unrelated well let me put
that without the negatives is I think
intuitively almost certainly related to
the profusion of the television speed
and the video games and everything else
that's going along with it and it seems
to me in given our current apparent
attention to education that we ought to
be paying Syria and I say we I mean
everyone and in particular parents and
teachers ought to be paying attention to
the fact that the kids come to school
with a with an unacknowledged curriculum
of sound bites and whiz-bang bells and
whistles and speed
and cuteness and all that stuff which we
you know kind of like but it has
metastasized or overflowed the banks to
the point at which teachers many
teachers at various levels study the
arts of entertainment because they don't
trust that they can deliver the arts of
thought in any other fashion and I I do
blame this in part for this this habit
of not knowing the difference between
opinions and arguments because on
television or in video and so on
everything's an opinion that is
everything's a statement this is so
that's not so I feel this I don't feel
that there are no arguments that are
possible here sort of well whatever you
know whatever I mean this is the big
whatever yeah so yeah that you feel that
way I think that this is a profound
educational burden it will not be
addressed by requiring more tests
because I have actually seen some of
that I've actually seen the tests that
are used in New York State which now
must be passed by high school graduates
and which is supposed to test reasoning
and research from documents and they are
a laugh you I've seen passing I've seen
examples of pass on these tests which
are truly embarrassing
they should be embarrassing for the
people who in the State Education
Commission who who ratified these tests
it should be an embarrassment for public
officials who purport to care about the
capacity to reason although in their own
discourse deliver very little of it I
think this is a you know this is a big
I'll use an overused word crisis that
people who care about education should
address two questions the first one I
think you'll agree that that the press
is you can't get much really good
information about them in the news and
I'm wondering if how much of you feel is
outright lies as opposed to just a sort
of omission and then for me
most of the American you mean the
newspapers television radio you know you
know the sort of commercial press I
guess outright lies are easy to find and
and constitute scandals that embarrass
everyone concerned I mean there was a
case a few weeks ago the reporter for
the New York Times Magazine was found to
have created composite characters in an
article he wrote about slavery in East
Africa and and so the New York Times
cleansed itself with a very long
editor's note explaining that this is a
violation of policy Geraldo Rivera
declared that he he was present at a
battle at which he was not present and I
think it's safe to say that he's not an
exemplary journalist that he's not going
to win awards for journalistic it is
true well we'll talk about that later
I've read the material on that no but
you have to read the the reporter for
the Baltimore Sun David feau conflic I
think did a very thorough okay we can
disagree in any case whether whether
Geraldo was a manufacturer of his
ostensible experience or not I don't
think lying is the problem I think that
timidity lack of curiosity or the
essential problems at our best I think
the press I think we think the New York
Times is a far better newspaper than it
was in an you know in the glory days of
the 1960s and that when they threw out
when they threw a lot of good reporters
out into the world after September 11th
they brought back a lot of news that was
really worth knowing about Pakistan
Egypt whose beckus Don the Philippines
and so on the problem is that these are
exceptional media and I say these I mean
I think
New York Times is and the you know
sometimes the LA Times is and sometimes
the networks are and that I don't think
anybody should feel smug in the face of
I don't I don't think anybody should
dismiss working journalists I think
they're I think that all the news
organizations that I've ever had any
contact with are full of serious
dedicated people who really care about
figuring things out and feel the burden
of their organizations and you know
they're they're they're not the problem
the problem is that the news
organizations have not been freestanding
Tribune's of enlightenment they have
been in the business of seizing
attention themselves and increasingly
this is for commercial purposes of do we
do we remember do we have the memory to
recall that last summer Walter Isaacson
upon taking helm of the taking the helm
of CNN declared that CNN was was now
going to do more celebrity and health
news that that's where that's where
these guys want to go because that they
know how to do that more surely than
they know how to do something that would
satisfy a deeper desire to figure out
what's going on in the world so I think
the I think the huge problem is and the
slippery slope that the whole news
business is on is toward drastic
simplification the you know easy
polarization of the world a kind of
cheap tabloid showmanship and and of
course I not how could I be in
Washington and not mention the fact that
they have political authorities who
welcome more of the same and by the way
this didn't just start with this
administration has been going on fairly
progressively or aggressively with some
exceptions since the Jimmy Carter
Administration the assumption that the
fundamental commitment of the
telecommunications business
ticular is toward the multiplication of
corporations rather than the serving of
a public good so that is certainly
implicated in all this we just had this
astounding decision within recent weeks
about enlarging the number of licenses
that corporations can hold and and then
and and making cross ownership easier
within a jurisdiction and and so on and
you know so clearly none of this is
governed none of this is governed by any
commitment to intelligence you know
we've heard a lot and we need to hear
more about failures of intelligence
before September 11th and certainly one
big one is the media's failure of
intelligence or two more two more
questions so what I'm going to do is ask
each of you to state your question and
then there's target one to kind of
combine them because we're beginning to
run out of time if you could the
questions I think in part you answered
the question I was about to ask but if
if this media that we have today works
so well in a commercial sense what
incentive is it is there for it to
change in any way in fact isn't it the
incentive to do more of what it's doing
rather than less
a fan of yours my question is really
isn't publishing which is also a media a
very much victim of this same phenomenon
of oversimplification and if in your own
book you had given your own historical
or theoretical orientation in Adorno
baudrillard de board etc the book would
have been dead in the water well let me
let me let me let me let me address the
second one first this book you know well
I don't want it to be scaring away
readers this book is this book is 244
text pages and of it well more than 30
hour footnotes are back notes so I don't
anybody wants to know my orientation
will will find that there amply I've
already been accused by many reviewers
of having read some books but you you
have my you have my orientation wrong
you mentioned Beaudry are for example
who i think is a is it very good for
those of you who would rather not know
mr. Beaudry are is an extremely
influential media critic in france who
perhaps most revealing li published an
essay and then a book in 1991 called the
gulf war did not take place i consider
him to be a fool and so you won't find i
hope any trace of my in debt my debt to
him in this book but no i you know this
is but but but more seriously I regard
it as my mission to be to be serious
without being without being tedious and
I am entirely not just content I mean I
demand of myself that I not trim what I
have to say I am very fortunate and
having
publisher that believes that there is a
place in public life for for serious
argument and that moreover thinks that
actually money can be made at it which
is an interesting problem that we don't
really have time to go into but one
thing I'll just say something quickly
about that the the geniuses who preside
over commercial media and this is often
true of publishing as well as as print
media make lots of rotten decisions all
the time and they're in a state of panic
I mean what was the what was the
Letterman Koppel thing about it's ABC
you know it's Disney Letterman ABC has
been we've been selling badly on the
stock market and so you have executives
thrashing around do something do
something oh well okay
Letterman's audience demographics are
four years younger than Koppel's oh that
sounds like a good idea well you know
these this is not thoughtful as I my
earlier book about the television
entertainment business in the course of
which I spent time in Hollywood
interviewing executives and trying to
figure out how they think convinced me
that most of their judgments are wrong I
mean at a time when the three networks
controlled 90% of American primetime and
after all the effort these people go
through to select television programs
for the next season more than 60% of the
shows they put on the air for the next
year failed failed by commercial lights
this is what's so interesting so I don't
know that these people are such Hot Shot
businessman as they claim to be either
the same thing is true in publishing and
you know panic you see the thing is we
need judgments to be made
bah and now I'm gonna veer back to the
first question I finally found thee the
hinge here do not consider that it that
in in this sense that a that a
professional should take the corruptions
of his or her institution lying down and
I say this by the way whether we're
talking about media institutions or
medical institutions or political
institutions were you
universities I think that all all
institutions are as paul tillich the
theologian once said demonic and the
mission of sure of professionals is to
do the professional work
the doctor has medical work to do the
writer the journalist the filmmaker have
their work to do
and they are bound to do it now you know
most people find reasons most of the
time to not go to the trouble because it
is trouble journalists I think many of
them you know talk among each other
about what to do in the face of this
process that is you know it's not new to
them that they are that they've been cut
back that they are given demeaning
assignments that they are not given the
time to do something worthy and in some
way I think you know they are in the
effort there they're deep in the effort
to try to do something ethical in this
as they feel yanked down the slippery
slope and we should encourage them to do
their best work we should not demonize
them we should not accuse them of being
you know lackeys of Rupert Murdoch alone
as if not not all of them are and let's
get about our business going over an
hour so I think together we have
successfully bucked the trend I think
Todd Gitlin his book media Unlimited is
for sale at the register and he is here
to sign I'm
Todd Gitlin days author of inside prime
time the whole world is watching and the
60s his latest media unlimited how the
torrent of images and sounds overwhelms
our lives is published by metropolitan
books a division of Henry Hilton company
visit Henry Holt comm for more
information